après de nouveau accrochage avec
l'Occident à propos des troupes russes
Macé à la frontière craignais la Russie
a dévoilé hier c'est proposition pour
limiter l'influence militaire des
États-Unis et de l'OTAN dans son
voisinage
du prêt à discuter en consultation avec
les Européens les détails avec notre
correspondante à Moscou Verhaeghe
Hoffman
la Russie propose aux États-Unis des
négociations sur les garanties de
sécurité exclusivement sur une base de
latérale l'application ou d'autres pays
les privés de leur sens à déclarer le
vice ministre des Affaires étrangères
Sergueï il a présenté hier en projet
d'accord avec l'Alliance atlantique qui
incluent des mesures comme l'engagement
des États-Unis à exclure l'élargissement
de le temps vers les notamment a des
pays de l'ex-URSS dont l'Ukraine parmi
les autres demandes du commun obtenir la
certitude que la collection ne construit
pas de base militaire dans le bloc
soviétique écouter
aujourd'hui de chaque pays ne peut être
assuré que par la voix de la coopération
dans le cadre du droit international de
viendront de membres de l'OTAN cela doit
être retiré
pire que la Russie et les États-Unis ne
se considère pas comme des adversaires
et que des mécanismes consultatifs sur
une base bilatérale multilatérale seront
utilisés pour résoudre les situations
problématiques il est également
important de réaffirmer le principe de
non-ingérence dans les affaires
d'intérieur de chacun
et on
est déjà en cours
la Russie peut-elle rester indifférente
à cette situation non c'est impossible
de
ces derniers mois n'ont fait que
les relations diplomatiques et doivent
le plus tôt possible